avec michel fize sociologue auteur du
livre de l'avim a l'espoir c'est aux
éditions mimesis bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous sur rt fransesco révèle selon
g l'existence même d'une telle note des
services de renseignement je crois que
cette note traduit une grande inquiétude
de l'exécutif qui est confronté
aujourd'hui à une concordance des
exaspérations et des frustrations qui se
manifestent vous l'avez rappelé comme en
2018 2019 pour les gilet jaune à
j'aurais quand même signaler une erreur
commise par les renseignements
territoriaux le mouvement des gilets
jaunes étaient tout sauf un mouvement
homogène on retrouve l hétérogénéité 1
dans ce mouvement il y avait des
ouvriers des employés des fonctionnaires
des retraités des chômeurs des petits
patrons difficultés des membres des
professions libérales
en clair des couches populaires des
couches moyennes des couches actives des
couches inactive et des hommes et des
femmes
voilà donc c'était tout sauf un
mouvement homogène organisée autour des
carburants 1 les carburants les
renseignements territoriaux n'ont pas
bien compris que c'était l'élément
fédérateur qui a déclenché ce mouvement
hétérogène qui a concerné effectivement
pour moitié les zones rurales et les
zones qu'on appelle suburbaines mais
également les zones urbaines donc les
grandes villes en particulier concernant
les codes de la manifestation que note
le sociologue que vous êtes savez je
pense que au delà des diversités
professionnels des diversités personnel
des motivations qui peuvent varier d'un
individu à un autre il y à cet élément
fédérateur qui est l'inquiétude pour les
libertés
car les antilles passe ou les antilles
fax
bach ce pardon pas fax sont des gens qui
encore une fois considère que ces
mesures sont anti libérale et que les
méthodes employées par ailleurs donc des
méthodes autoritaires un des méthodes
venue d'un seul homme sont également des
mesures anti libérale on a même parlé de
deuil de liberticide donc y'a rien des
terreaux gêne dans cette affaire un au
contraire c'est parfaitement homogène
est ce que comme le mouvement des îles
et jaune le mouvement anti pas sanitaire
peut durer savez je pense que ce que
nous voyons aujourd'hui c'est une colère
fédératrice à la mesure des souffrances
endurées
car les français souffrent ils souffrent
beaucoup
il souffre de plus en plus et on a cette
formidable mal malheureuse situation de
revenus qui stagnent qui augmentent très
très faiblement et de charges qui elle
n'en finissent pas de grimper
allez donc voir les prix des fruits et
légumes dans les points de vente
commerciaux 1
et puis c'est sans parler de l'énergie
qui est de plus en plus cher donc on
annonce des des augmentations
faramineuses pour le gaz
dd annonce également sont faites sur
l'augmentation probable de l'électricité
l'année prochaine donc là il ya un
décalage énorme entre un discours je
dirais macroéconomiques qui nous parle
de retour de la croissance qui nous
parle de baisse du chômage qui nous
parle de cette formidable épargne fait
parler français encore une fois quand
même les plus favorisés au cours de la
période de confinement et puis ces
situations personnelles misérables
presque au sens de hugo du terme 1,2 de
gens qui n'arrivent pas encore une fois
à boucler les fins de mois
donc si situation n'ont fait qu'empirer
avec la crise sanitaire donc bien
évidemment que ce mouvement
va se poursuivre donc à la hauteur d
insatisfaction par rapport à ces
situations qui ne sont pas résolues un
tout derniers mois assez rapidement si
vous le voulez bien
selon la note des renseignements le
mouvement dit pas sanitaire serait super
par une majorité de gilet jaune et on en
a vus manifester
ces deux derniers week-ends qu'est-ce
que ça laisse présager selon vous est ce
que c'est une forme de renaissance aussi
du combat chez les jeunes je crois que
il ya une continuité d'abord dans le
mouvement il ya aussi des dg jaune
donc je crois que sont fédérés à la fois
d insatisfaction par rapport à
l'insécurité économique et social par
rapport à l'insécurité sanitaire et puis
des craintes par rapport à nos libertés
qui sont est égratignée au fil du temps
merci beaucoup pour votre regard michel
fize sociologue je rappelle le titre de
votre dernier ouvrage de l'abyme à
l'espoir c'est aux éditions mais c'est
ce merci à vous et à bientôt sur rt
francs merci